guys our Fandango fans are flipping out
about the release of Mockingjay part 2
what would you guys say is the best way
for them to prep for getting ready to
watch the last movie I mean slow down on
your liquids make sure you go to the
bathroom there's not really a good time
so to get up I want to see if you guys
can separate Hunger Games fact from
fiction so I'm gonna read a whole bunch
of things because there's so much
information out there about these movies
you tell me what's fact and what's
fiction this will be easy okay in a
failed attempt to show off your amazing
kicking prowess Jen you once gave Josh a
kick to the head and a concussion oh
yeah that is true yeah that's true Liam
to help you prepare for your auditions
your brother Chris would play Katniss
stop Chris said that's not what Chris
said no women we've run lines before but
he was another country I think when it
when the first one came around so he
told you he did it he did tell me to
stop eating food because it's cold
hunger games not eating games
it took a team of 60 stylists 9 hours
every day to create Katniss braid ha ha
that's not true 59 no I just took a wig
it took sixty five hundred thousand pins
but no knots Tyler clearly not your
favorite part of it 65 hundred thousand
is a number is not guys I'm a middle
school dropout don't read my vision Josh
you've been known to bust a move to
Beyonce's single ladies
during partying while on set it's
actually a fiction that one what
articularly isn't fiction connects I
would not dancer that song I would never
dance it okay your pets by yourself no
interview these things I will never I
read that you and sam claflin did that
nope I'm sure Sam did yes and whatever
done that but Josh isn't a magical more
ghetto hard-hitting gangster she is okay
okay Jen you temporarily lost hearing in
one year due to a double ear infection
from the water stunt I had a double year
infection from just being in the water
I'll attack during Catching Fire and
then
while I had the infection I jumped into
waters that were creating the jet to
make the island spin around that whole
thing and then the jet pushed the
infection into my eyes not affecting her
brain of here's ear lobe and now I'm
fine I just have to keep my head
likelihoods finally by the time filming
ended Jen you had contributed 1.2
million dollars to the onset swear jar
yeah I don't know why I keep getting by
the time I did she owed 1.2 million why
Dickens contribution never happen oh I
can't believe I didn't pay it
Oh